the climactic battle for the speakership
breaking overnight the house officially
elected Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the
House after four nights and 15
contentious rounds of voting McCarthy
narrowly secured the speaker's gavel and
took the oath of office but a late
Friday night fumble briefly stalled his
bid tensions boiled over as McCarthy
confronted Republican holdout Matt gates
after the Florida representative voted
present Dylan McCarthy a stunning defeat
in the 14th round Republicans regrouped
for an historic post-midnight 15th
ballot to help the ninth term
congressman from California become the
55th Speaker of the House Christina
raffini is at the Capitol with the very
latest Christina I was texting you last
night Netflix could not have played this
out any better good morning to you what
more can you tell us good morning you
know who needs Netflix when you have
C-SPAN and a Twitter account on a Friday
night uh look it was a high stakes high
drama evening when the house reconvened
around 10 pm Kevin McCarthy took that
floor thinking he had the votes but that
didn't turn out to be the case in that
first round and for a while there it
looked like we could go the weekend
without a seated House of
Representatives but then just around the
stroke of midnight McCarthy's
parliamentary pumpkin turned into a
speaker of the house
it's my high honor and distinct
privilege to finally
be able to Welcome All of You
to the 118th Congress
foreign
McCarthy the 15th time was the charm
after a contentious
[Applause]
and dramatic midnight vote
McCarthy
following the first round of the evening
two of McCarthy's loudest Republican
critics Florida's Matt Gates and
Colorado's Lauren bobert voted present
both refusing to give McCarthy the one
vote he needed to grab the gavel
frustrations boiled over into a physical
altercation with Alabama Republican Mike
Rogers appearing to Lunge towards Gates
as a colleague held him back Madam clerk
I Rise to say wow then with a motion to
adjourn on the table in exchange of
words and a breakthrough
there was another vote
other holdouts changing their votes to
present thereby lowering the number
McCarthy needed to win some would call
it shambolic even
but
it's called democracy the pre-dawn
resolution followed four days of furious
negotiations between McCarthy and
members of his own party the new speaker
made several concessions including
making it easier for any member to oust
the speaker and giving his Republican
opponents two seats on the rules
committee I think what you will see by
having this now
we've worked out how to work together
you know
the agenda the house needs to pass a
rules package which will enable them to
do things like pass legislation Michelle
we're expecting them to vote on that
this Monday
still a lot of work there for them
Christina raffini thank you